[Music]
Jeremih tower is considered to be by
some to be the Godfather of modern
American cooking but many people don't
know his name adieu a new documentary
aims to change that and it will Jeremiah
towers his name
the last magnificent love that title
Anthony highlights and chefs tumultuous
career and long lasting impact chef and
TV host Anthony Bourdain executive
produced the documentary he did it out
of a quote sense of rage and historical
injustice that people don't know towers
contributions to American cuisine in the
seven days Alice Waters opens Chez
Panisse you cannot begin to understand
the impact on the food landscape 1972
Jeremiah tower walks into Chez Panisse
everyone reluctantly or not half to a
tree that he put the place on the map
Jeremiah towers menus made Chez Panisse
the place that everybody wanted to go
a complete reevaluation of not just
American food and ingredients but food
tower unexpectedly walked away after
years in the spotlight he left his role
as a famous chef for a quiet life in
Mexico tower and Bourdain also recently
republished Towers memoirs in the new
book start the fire how I began a food
revolution in America Jeremiah Tower and
Anthony Bourdain good morning good
morning
they're here so so Anthony you call
Jeremiah the Chuck Berry of modern
American cooking tell us what you mean
by that he changed you know everything
he was somebody with a unique voice a
unique vision who came along and changed
not just the way we eat the way we
looked at American ingredients and
American sourcing and the role of the
chef in in the dining scene as suddenly
the shepherd in some you actually wanted
to see in the dining room and agony
water didn't even want to tell people
they were chef Baxter hell yeah and then
it became stars and then stars which
really transformed the you know in many
ways created the template for the way we
eat in America now the open kitchen then
why so many people not know more about
Jeremiah and I knew about him from
something we've done together but um you
know victory is written by the winners
they say I'm sorry uh history is written
by the victors I think Jeremiah wasn't
around for a while it allowed people to
create out of I think laziness a largely
out of laziness a narrative that
persisted and people became more
invested in all this well you know after
35 years of shaking 350 people's hands a
day I just decided I need a little quiet
you know just to balance all that noise
and and then I want a little quiet from
the beer I was so much more than that in
this documentary they describe this
wasn't really Bono I fell in love with
you I really did I couldn't wait to meet
you today when Anthony came I said hey
when's he coming glamour puss a darling
a sexy chef men and women wanted to
sleep with you everybody in the room was
great but Jeremiah was
red but you were also considered very
prickly and very controversial in how
you behaved in the kitchen how did you
see yourself back then well you know the
whenever I got prickly I'll just have a
glass of champagne and that cured that
but I was put on some operas but it's
when you're trying to do the best at
every moment of every day and that
sounds pretentious but actually you know
that's what it takes in a good
restaurant someone said the other day
what did you suffer fools gladly and I
said absolutely not of course not you
know how could I if I was going to make
a restaurant like stars but when you
went to Chez Panisse because you
literally walked in off the street right
and there's some controversy as to who
really created the California cuisine
wasn't you or Alice Waters and people
were saying give Alice ordure they're
saying Jeremiah shut up but you said
look I created that menu I created that
food well one of the conditions I said
to accept doing this documentary I said
we have to go the high road with Alice
but on the other hand the point is well
made in the film that you know she
claimed to have done everything but it's
always teamwork and certainly the menus
were my work so I decided as long as
Anthony said you know speak up I thought
I would oh why are you back now yeah
we're on my back well you know in order
to meet all of you know you want to be a
back in the kitchen no no no no I mean
the Leslie hesitatingly because we know
because everybody wants to be able to do
what made them who they are has right
right and what if it was on the Amalfi
Coast or you know a little beach bar in
Phuket true or just came back from
Seville and I thought well okay I found
a location there and I thought this is
very possible but you came back and to
do Tavern on the Green
and Anthony at the time you said holy
bleep why is he doing that yeah I mean
it's really one of the legendarily one
of the hardest and most difficult jobs
for a chef on the planet it's something
of a thankless mission and I think we
were all astonished that Jeremiah I mean
I think you discount how much of a
romantic you are bit take real a
romantic attitude to to go into a place
it doesn't 700 700 dinners that kind of
volume that stuff but you thought you
could turn it around yeah and then you
left I mean but I how are you connected
to him what's the direct line read
Jeremiah's memoir originally titled the
California dish and was very moved by it
and outraged by what I saw as a sort of
injustice of the the the received
history of California and a new American
cooking and I thought the book also made
me realize that I've been cooking dishes
that were influenced by Jeremiah's work
for much of my career without even
knowing they were Jeremiah's work like
what I think of the lobster the gazpacho
all right and it's with the lobster or
the Google fish you know so much of what
I'd learned and second and third hand
over the years some of the restaurants
I'd worked in had been directly affected
and changed by this great innovator and
at first I thought I I would like to
step in and do what I kind of correct
the record that was the original impetus
for the film you did that but it's also
I think it's a great character story
about about what it takes to be a great
chef and and the potential perils and
costs of the elaborate excellent so this
is a guy who reads menus like books I
mean you could you could see a story
just in a menu right you could do that
right and I was always fascinated by
menus because as when I was five years
old we were in Sydney and restaurant
called prune yay and I was allowed to go
out with my parents it was dark and I'd
fall asleep at the table but I learned
my game was to be able to read the
French menu
I wish your grace your game was being
great with food get back here
get back in well done - thank you and
Chuck very never gave up oh right
charlie that's Lydia tamales motto never
give up that we should listen to Lydia
yeah
Jeremiah tower the last magnificent is
in theaters Friday you can hear more of
our CBS